[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parle et sport sur TV à 78 l'émission ne
surtout pas avoir manqué si vous êtes un
passionné de sport local aujourd'hui
comme toujours il y aura des analyses
techniques des décryptages et surtout
une dose de bonne humeur pour
m'accompagner nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous sur ce plateau ils sont en pleine
forme à l'approche du printemps
présentation en musique de cette
magnifique dream team on commence à ma
droite musique l'étude nouvelle fois
dans cette émission c'est un pistard de
niveau international il a été champion
du monde de cyclisme sur piste master
s'il est spécialistes cyclisme mais s'y
connaît dans tous les sports en voile en
roller Pokémon Go aussi bon ça c'est
pour les petites blagues le capitaine y
a du Jarrier est avec nous pendant une
heure comment allez-vous bonsoir Michael
très très bien on fait bien en forme du
printemps et oui ça y est les
températures commencent à remonter on va
pouvoir profiter pleinement alors on
continue notre tour de table à gauche
musique c'est l'un des piliers de cette
émission c'est l'un des un journaliste
au Monde sur le sport italien et sur le
sport yvelinois c'est une véritable
légende vivante c'est notre John Luigi
et Buffon à nous notre italienne over
Grégory canalet est avec nous bonsoir
Yann bonsoir à tous Comment allez-vous
bah écoutez très bien au niveau du
football italien puisque c'est ce qui me
passionne le plus on est plutôt sur de
bons hospices avec peut-être à trois sur
trois alors on se parle de club italien
qualifiés en quart de finale de Ligue
des Champions ce qui n'était plus arrivé
depuis très longtemps en 2005-2006 voilà
l'Italie qui aura peut-être trois
représentants en quart de finale je vais
pas parler trop vite mais pas comme la
France on en parlera dans un instant
justement vu un petit teasing de votre
part Grégory cannelés on passe de
l'autre côté musique c'est un petit
nouveau ilonore déjà sa quatrième
sélection dans cette émission il est
responsable sponsoring chez Orange en
Île-de-France il adore le sport il vibre
pour le sport mesdames et messieurs
Philippe volak nous fait l'honneur de
venir dans cette émission bonjour à tous
Comment allez-vous Philippe en pleine
allant
comme on dirait hier soir avec 5 buts de
Allende donc je suis à peine alors
vous êtes l'un des plus sérieux pour
préparer à l'émission avec Yann je tiens
à le dire quand même je sais pas mais
bon oui je la prépare parce que bon j'ai
à faire des mauvais élèves notamment un
c'est ça en face de l'autre côté musique
c'est la star de ce plateau des milliers
de fans l'attendent à la sortie de nos
studios pour un selfie ou un autographe
c'est coup de gueule sur Meetic ces
analyses sont à chaque fois pertinentes
coach Jean Miss ex entraîneur de plaisir
est avec nous bonsoir Michael bonsoir à
tous bonsoir les copains
la préparation des émissions j'ai pris
pour moi ça va
je prépare à ça vraiment très
sérieusement d'ailleurs je vais vous
prouver dès cette émission vous allez
voir les fans qui vous attendent à
l'extérieur vous avez réussi vous
faufiler jusqu'à mon studio
du personnage pour ce profiler
c'est franchement
qui commence très fort à vouloir y
compris
de l'émission on va parler de cross
country Jeanne le corps licencié à lea
50 ans en Yvelines qu'on a l'habitude de
suivre sur tb78 a connu quelques
déboires ce week-end lors des
championnats de France de cross country
à Carré la 56 noise avec quasiment gagné
la course junior dames et à 500 mètres
de l'arrivée elle a été victime d'un
malaise avant d'entamer le final vers
d'arriver comme vous pouvez le voir sur
ces images ne remportera pas cette année
son troisième titre mais rassurez-vous
la championne de 17 ans va bien et les
sperce relever de cette déception votre
avis sur cette séquence rarissime dans
le monde du sport Grégory déjà grosse
pensée pour elle parce que voilà c'est
cette défaillance à 500 mètres de
l'arrivée quand le titre lui tendait les
bras ça doit être très difficile pour
elle et après voilà c'est aussi
l'exigence du du sport de haut niveau
c'est un pondérable aussi qui peuvent
arriver on a beau se préparer être au
top physiquement on peut être aussi
victime de genre de de défaillance moi
ça me fait penser notamment à sur un
autre sport mais on reste dans dans les
sports athlétiques Yohann Diniz aussi
sur les nombreux jeux olympiques où il a
connu des défaillances on se souvient
tous de ses premiers gastriques lors des
JO de Rio c'était assez difficile à
avoir il a eu aussi une nouvelle
défaillance à Tokyo voilà dans le sport
de haut niveau c'est des choses qui
peuvent arriver
qui peuvent sur le coup alors je sais
pas si ça fait sourire ça peut faire
peur mais c'est des choses qui peuvent
arriver et en tout cas grosse pensée
pour elle parce que ça va être difficile
de voir le titre lui échapper de cette
manière Philippe voilà que vous avez
regardé la course ouais j'ai regardé la
course j'ai vu le replay et je me suis
dit enfin surtout après au niveau des
des autres coureuses ils ont dit que
toute la semaine ils pensaient vraiment
comment la course et tout ça qui il
s'alimentait mal il pensait qu'à ça et
en fin de compte je pense que c'est avec
le stress en plus je pense que que ça a
joué pour elle ça a joué le stress les
conditions étaient pas bon non plus la
bon le cross c'est ça aussi c'est la
boue c'est tout ça mais je veux dire là
je pense que la semaine qui était en
amont je pense que ça a dû ça a dû jouer
le soir voilà je pense que c'était trop
selon vous les conditions le stress les
conditions je pense que c'est plus le
stress et puis le le c'est les France
quand même c'est le France enfin quand
même je veux dire donc la pression elle
est quand même encore beaucoup plus
forte quand même mais là en plus ce
qu'elle avait cause gagné je sais pas si
elle savait ça y est parce que elle
avait quand même beaucoup d'avance
qu'elle avait en plus peut-être le
stress aussi qui va gagner enfin qui
reste plus que 500 mètres donc je pense
que le sec et va gagner et puis et puis
voilà bon ça s'écroule et comme pour
dire celles qui sont arrivés deuxième
ils ont dit j'ai pas gagné la course
celle qui est arrivé deuxième la dit
j'ai pas été Clermont-Ferrand je crois
elle a pas elle a pas gagné la course
parce que dit non c'est pas moi qui ai
gagné par contre c'est consolé avec le
par équipe parce que la vie j'ai plus
fêté par équipe que que comme mon cas
individuel parce que c'est pas moi qui
ai gagné mais voilà on peut pas enlever
ça malheureusement
c'est c'est le sport c'est la beauté du
sport c'est le dépassement maintenant
il faut quand même se comprendre et
savoir pourquoi c'est arrivé parce que
en effet elle accorce gagner
c'est-à-dire que si elle est en
difficulté physique rien ne lui empêche
de lever le pied et de finir les 500
derniers mètres en courant 10 15
secondes de moins on sait que sur une
allure c'est quand même une grosse
différence de dépenses énergétique
surtout à ce niveau-là donc là en fait
ce qu'il faudrait pas c'est que il reste
une empreinte dans le dans le cerveau et
de se dire bah est-ce que ça va pas me
ré arriver je sais que ça peut la
marquer sur les prochaines courses
et oui bien sûr ça peut sur n'importe
quelle épreuve bien sûr ça peut marquer
parce que elle pourrait se dire enfin si
elle ne comprend pas ce qui s'est
produit ben ça peut elle pourrait se
dire ça peut m'arriver à n'importe quel
moment donc là il faut être capable
d'analyser et de peut-être comprendre et
ressentir les prémices de ce malaise
pour pouvoir les éviter à nouveau parce
que c'est vrai que quand on est sportif
de haut niveau comme comme cette comme
c'est ta tête mais on est capable de de
repousser la douleur et de dire non non
je veux mais là il y a eu le corps et le
cerveau a mis un vrai stop un fusible il
a dit là c'est bon tu tu n'avances plus
on l'a quand même très très rarement vu
ou alors des vraies accidents donc donc
je pense que là il y a quand même un
vrai une vraie recherche derrière à
faire pour comprendre ce qui s'est ce
qui s'est produit parce que oui comme tu
dis ça peut être très bien lié à la à la
semaine de préparation et pas seulement
à l'intensité du de l'effort les
conditions étaient très très
particulières mais ça reste du cross et
puis enfin voilà la gestion de l'effort
à ce niveau là ils savent ce que c'est
quoi donc
il est moi je pense qu'il y a il faut se
poser les thèmes des questions pour
éviter que ça puisse se reproduire aussi
c'est que la saison de cross se termine
bien sûr ils vont passer sur la piste là
pour la plupart donc je pense que ça va
l'aider à rebondir à rebondir
genre qu'est-ce que vous en pensez mais
pour reprendre un peu ce que ce que mes
70 c'est que il faut il faut le savoir
effectivement parce que est-ce que c'est
physique le problème ou est-ce que c'est
duel mauvaise préparation mentalement je
pense pas que ce mental là c'est
purement physique mental quand on est
sur le point de à 500 mètres de
l'arrivée au cross qu'on gagne et le
mental on l'a pas déjà gagné deux fois
deux fois parce que
vous pouvez gagner éventuellement
qu'elle pouvait gagner donc là le
problème est physique donc à savoir si
c'est un problème physiologique ou si
c'est le problème par rapport à la
préparation de cette semaine et de cette
compétition comme Philippe l'avancée et
c'est là aussi moi je rebondis c'est là
aussi où l'importance de
l'accompagnement du sportif est
important parce que est-ce que cette
sportive de haut niveau est bien
accompagnée peut-être pas parce que si
c'est vraiment un problème mais de
préparation avec une malnutrition entre
guillemets de préparation de ce niveau
là ben là il y a quand même quelques
quelques quelques questions à se poser
pour que justement ça ça ne se
reproduise pas l'important pour moi
c'est de savoir exactement enfin pour
tout le monde de savoir exactement le
pourquoi du comment
cette défaillance on le voit c'est une
défaillance physique ou elle tombe en
malaise vagal alors que alors que alors
qu'elle a gagné une question de gestion
c'est pas du tout la gestion parce que
effectivement elle peut très bien couper
court et puis finir en roue libre même
en marchant à la limite elle a gagné
certainement donc c'est vraiment un
problème physique et le pourquoi du
comment je pense qu'il faut
l'approfondir mais aussi de
l'accompagnement des sportifs de haut
niveau c'est là qu'on voit que
l'importance de de ces gens là qui sont
autour des sportifs de haut niveau ça
arrivera on en parlera rarement ça
arrive régulièrement ou pas je sais pas
en rugby ou qui est de côte de rugby
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu ce type de
malaise ça arrive mais c'est souvent lié
justement à des problèmes physiques à
des problèmes vraiment des problèmes
profonds physiques les malformations
cardiaques ou des choses comme ça on a
toujours vu dans Ford malheureusement
des des drames arrivaient mais parce que
à tous les niveaux d'ailleurs que ce
soit jeune ou seniors à tous les niveaux
on a vu des sportifs avoir des des
malaises et malheureusement des malaises
fatales donc ça c'est
là ça arrive pas souvent heureusement
d'ailleurs heureusement puisque c'est
c'est là qui est là et qui est prépondé
près de ton prédominant par là la
préparation physique des sportifs de
haut niveau des petits coups de moins
bien ça peut arriver même sur les
terrains de foot parce que moi c'est
tant que que je pratique pour pour le
coup les chaos c'est vraiment quand il y
a des chocs entre les joueurs là un
blackout total comme comme on l'a eu là
moi j'en ai j'en ai rarement vu en tout
cas pas sur les terrains de football
c'est c'est assez rare oui un peu plus
de 6 km pour ceux qui se posent la
question de de ce terrain de cross
country c'était une boucle voilà c'est
donc un peu plus de sécurité
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler
de box et de la défaite de livinois Tony
Yoka face à Carlos Takam nous parlerons
aussi du Paris-Nice 2023 qui est parti
depuis allez-yvelines mais avant de
parler de ces thématiques on va parler
du PSG
[Musique]
on va donc parler du PSG de la défaite
du PSG en Ligue des Champions c'est le
thème de votre volley Grégory alors le
moment le plus fort de cette émission
qui arrive très vite ouais vous vous
montez en grade alors c'est à VOUS quoi
mais effectivement on va parler de cette
énorme désillusion le Paris
Saint-Germain et éliminé de la Ligue des
Champions il n'y a pas eu débat face au
Bayern Munich en 8e de finale bien mieux
expérimenté bien mieux armés pour rêver
d'empocher la coupe aux grandes oreilles
un non match à l'aller une défaite imbu
à zéro les espoirs de remontada semblait
20 au retour au vu des absences Neymar
en premier lieu et d'une rencontre qui
se disputait à l'extérieur mais pourquoi
pas après tout Paris a bien fait
illusion le temps d'une mi-temps contre
un Bayern certes appliqué mais pas
impressionnant elle est parisien ont eu
l'occasion d'ouvrir le score mais
vitigna seul au but a été l'auteur
d'arrêter incroyable ajouter à cela un
brin de malchance les sorties la sortie
prématurée sur blessure et du capitaine
marquin remplacer par mukieller juste
avant la mi-temps lui-même obligé de
céder sa place au retour des vestiaires
aux jeunes bitchouabus et 17 ans qui se
souviendra encore longtemps de son
baptême du feu par se met le tout
d'erreur individuelles manifeste et vous
obtenez une soirée cauchemardesque et
cette défaite de à zéro avec un but
marqué pour ne rien arranger par l'ex
parisien Choupo Moting une fois de plus
le PSG sort des 8e de finale de la Ligue
des Champions la cinquième fois en 7
Édition une fois de plus les supporters
doivent se contenter de ne jouer que la
Ligue 1 cette saison le parti le Paris
Saint-Germain ou l'art tout simplement
de la non progression en Ligue des
Champions malgré la lumière les stars et
les moyens à mis sur la table l'ambition
a été affichée par le propriétaire
qatari dès son arrivée en 2011 remporté
la plus prestigieuse des compétitions
européennes et les premières années
étaient plutôt encourageantes il faut le
dire un certes le club de la capitale ne
passait pas le stade des quarts de
finale de la Ligue des Champions mais
c'était vite installé dans le gotha du
niveau européen et des bases saines
créées par Carlo Ancelotti une idée de
jeu porté par Laurent Blanc et puis il y
a eu ce tournant en 2017 pour la
première fois depuis l'air qatari Paris
sort des les 8e de finale la fameuse
Raymond tada face au FC Barcelone se
naufrage siburant au Camp Nou malgré une
victoire 4 à 0 à l'aller et depuis les
Parisiens attendent de sortir la tête de
l'eau à coups de millions 400 millions
d'euros pour Neymar et Mbappe 40
millions d'euros de salaire pour Messi
un salaire qui est bien sûr par saison
c'est 40 millions par saison au total
depuis 2011 c'est 1,5 millions d'euros
qui a été dépensé par le Paris
Saint-Germain pour une balance des
transferts négatives d'un milliard
d'euros Paris est devenu une marque plus
qu'une équipe au détriment d'un
déséquilibre financier d'un déséquilibre
dans son effectif devenu bancal les deux
années en trompe l'oeil 2020 une finale
de Ligue des champions dans une formule
inédite 2021 et l'élimination en
demi-finale ils changeront rien c'est
une triste réalité la gestion du club et
désastreuse un exemple parmi tant
d'autres l'affaire Serge Aurier en 2016
un joueur qui insulte son coach qui est
mis au banc de l'effectif avant d'être
réintégré très rapidement dans le groupe
beaucoup trop d'erreurs ont été commises
pour progresser et aujourd'hui le PSG à
mon sens n'a jamais été aussi loin de la
cour des grands un joueur incarne cette
non progression du côté parisien c'est
Marco verratti l'italien pourtant
pétrite talon n'a pas vraiment évolué
depuis son arrivée en 2012 coupable
souvent des mêmes erreurs tout le temps
en train de discuter avec l'arbitre une
hygiène de vie contestable mais pourtant
toujours confortablement installé au
sein de l'effective parisien de
l'effectif parisien aux côtés de son
compère Neymar dont on parlait déjà la
dernière fois dans le SEP contre le
Bayern c'est verratti qui a perdu deux
fois le ballon qui amène les buts
bavarois la première perte de balle et
criminel même si son coach Christophe
Galtier a tenté en conférence de presse
d'après match de rejeter la faute sur
son jeunes défenseur à bu vous
savez ce gamin de 17 ans dont je vous
parlais il y a un instant à qui faisait
ses débuts en Ligue des Champions avec
le Paris Saint-Germain
erreur de gestion erreur de com bref
rien ne va plus au PSG il est temps de
faire table rase du passé et d'enfin
faire les bons choix pour remettre le
PSG sur de bon rails faire également la
paix avec les supporters un passablement
agacé et ça peut se comprendre les
solutions je ne les ai pas peut-être
qu'autour de la table vous avez quelques
pistes de solution pour sortir le PSG de
cette crise mais permettez-moi une
suggestion et ça va peut-être permettre
d'ouvrir le débat pas sûr que de quitter
le Parc des Princes comme semble vouloir
les dirigeants parisiens sur la
meilleure idée pour retrouver l'amour de
leur supporter
Grégory qui a sorti à la sulfateuse un
boulot et compris dans cette envolée on
est tous un peu bouche bé autour de
cette table votre avis a tout simplement
sur ce coup de gueule et cette
élimination qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
Philippe voilà nos commandes non bon
voilà
moi-même qui suit
supporter de fou genre de foot je suis
je suis déçu je veux dire ça fait 11 ans
que le QC là ça fait la cinquième
élimination en ces temps en huitième de
finale
je vois rien je vois rien je vois rien
progresser c'est en haut c'est c'est
partout c'est le bon on l'a vu c'est
médiocre on a vu le bon contre le Bayern
c'était quand on voit le banc du Bayern
c'est c'était impressionnant par rapport
qui est rentré après c'est sûr on dit on
va dire que que comment Marquinho s'est
sorti mais Marquinhos est sorti faudra
peut-être pas fallu faire rentrer parce
que à l'entraînement il a déjà ressenti
une douleur ils l'ont sûrement voilà
apaisé mais au bout d'une demi-heure il
remplace par quelqu'un ou qui elle est
qui est aussi blessé et et 10 minutes
après vous qui allez sort à la mi-temps
aussi parce que vous avez peut-être pas
le choix ils avaient ils avaient pas le
choix je ne disait tranquille
et puis après bon ben pour revenir sur
le cas verratique que tu disais bah
verratti on a appris dans la presse il y
a pas longtemps là que deux jours avant
à 6h 6h il était en boîte et il était
pas dans son état normal de nuit avant
il y a quand même quelque chose il y a
quelque chose à faire en haut à punir je
sais pas il y a il faut il faut tout
changer mais je pense qu'il faut passer
par le haut c'est pas l'entraîneur c'est
sûr que l'entraîneur c'est c'est
l'institution qu'il faut qu'il faut
changer mais on n'a pas l'impression
qu'ils veulent changer l'institution au
Qatar mais quelle est la raison pour
laquelle un joueur comme verratti puisse
se retrouver en boîte deux jours avant
un match de Ligue des Champions quoi
aussi important comment comment ça pue
ça peut lui traverser l'esprit de dire
ouais je vais aller en boîte je vais
aller faire la fête avec les copains non
mais mec eh oh tu tu tu te fais les gars
sont câblés comment quoi comment ils
sont câblés où est-ce qu'il est où
est-ce que ça peut te traverser l'esprit
moi-même quand je prépare une petite
course mais deux jours avant je suis le
moine quoi et je pense que
par exemple voilà je suis pas souvent de
Neymar mais verratti c'est l'autre
joueur un peu à Niger
quel qu'il soit de toute façon
les deux sont assez amis
il est souvent dans dans les bons coups
en boîte de nuit et cetera voilà mais il
fait plus parler de lui en dehors du
terrain que sur le terrain oui
et il s'affiche en plus il a été pris
plusieurs fois sur le fait non mais
alors là c'est pareil même juste ça on
sait que c'est de la merde pour tout le
monde de tabac mais comment je suis
sportif de haut niveau je vais pouvoir
me dire ouais ben moi je vais fumer et
je vais montrer aux autres que mais non
mais si tu le fais tu le fais
discrètement mais en plus je vais
pourrir mes capacités de toute façon je
je
mais c'est vrai que pour moi il a un
carnet
c'est quelqu'un de pétri de talent c'est
pareil il y a un gros potentiel et enfin
bon on est quand même déçu c'est c'est
on remet pas en cause le talent des
joueurs loin de là ni de l'entraîneur
d'ailleurs mais en effet c'est là on
parle d'encadrement pour pour la petite
jeune mais là c'est pareil c'est à dire
que les mecs mais c'est même pas
l'encadrement c'est de l'éducation c'est
de l'éducation c'est des choses que l'on
apprend en école de foot c'est des
choses comment ça se fait que les gars
puissent se dire mais moi je suis au
dessus de ça et je suis plus fort et
donc je vais pouvoir le faire non il
n'est pas possible c'est pas possible on
l'a compris il n'ira pas au Pacha club
juste avant une course de 5 km en tout
cas à l'avenir je vais pas au resto
avant une course j'ai refusé un apéro
samedi soir parce que je courais
dimanche après-midi vous voulez pas
appeler Marco verratti pour lui donner
des conseils
genre Miss du coup qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous sur
qui vous tirez à balle réel vraiment je
je tire pas spécialement la règle parce
que là le mâle est profond quand même et
on s'aperçoit à travers le PSG que
aligner des stars à côté
l'une de l'autre ne fait pas une grosse
équipe ça c'est certain on le sait
depuis longtemps moi je l'avais déjà dit
sur ce plateau que c'est pas parce qu'on
a les meilleurs joueurs du monde qu'on
aura une grande équipe je crois que
c'est Pelé qui avait dit ça un jour
mais le fait est quand même que là c'est
le mâle est plus profond le mal est que
le football est un sport collectif et
qu'aujourd'hui plutôt que d'avoir
peut-être des stars internationales qui
soi-disant je dis bien soi-disant son
meilleur joueur du monde mais moi c'est
le résultat qui compte moi quand on
arrête pas de me dire que Neymar c'est
un des meilleurs joueurs du monde mais
je sais pas je sais pas je suis pas un
pro du foot mais quand même le résultat
est que ce mec là il joue comme une
temps il est toujours blessé et c'est
quoi les meilleurs les meilleurs joueurs
il était pas là sur le match de Ligue
des Champions
et je veux dire une chose c'est que là
le mal est profond là le mâle est
profond pour moi aujourd'hui il faut que
le PSG fasse table rase et qui repartent
avec un autre fonctionnement et un état
d'esprit est-ce qu'il peut le faire de
sport collectif je ne sais pas s'ils
peuvent le faire mais aujourd'hui on se
pose la question de savoir on sait que
les milliards parce que c'est même plus
des millions des milliards ne font rien
les milliards ne font rien aligner des
stars l'une à côté des autres ça fait
pas une grande équipe d'accord
aujourd'hui on a on a des équipes en
Ligue 1 c'est Reims je conseille
zéro star et pourtant ils ont à 10
victoires
1900 mais il manque il manque un état
d'esprit il manque quelque chose il
manque et à un moment donné il va
falloir se poser des vraies questions
parce que aujourd'hui mais l'échec il
est il est profond il est pas sur deux
trois saisons là il y a des
investissements financiers qui est là et
en plus c'est pas les résultats et en
plus on continue à dire que c'est les
meilleurs du monde pourquoi voulez-vous
humainement quand on dit un joueur comme
Neymar mettez le meilleur du monde mais
pourquoi il changerait quoi pourquoi il
changerait alors que alors que pour moi
c'est une pompe alors pourquoi il
changerait le garçon
pourquoi les entraîneurs les ex
entraîneurs du PSG et les ex joueurs du
PSG
brillent ailleurs
non mais on a déjà dit l'entraîneur sont
partis ils ont gagné la coupe la Coupe
d'Europe de club champions donc
est-ce qu'ils peuvent le faire ou pas
c'est moi qui les clés mais on va donner
je parle du côté du côté sportif et du
côté sportif aujourd'hui ce ce canevas
ne fonctionne pas donc aujourd'hui il va
falloir que je pose peut-être les vraies
questions peut-être que ils ont besoin
autant de stars et d'aligner les
millions comme ils font il faut
peut-être qu'ils prennent à des gens qui
ont envie de mouiller le maillot mais
est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils vont
changer de système
ma conviction c'est il y a encore des
fantômes de 2017 hein cette Raymond tada
ils gèrent toujours au sein du PSG et
aussi parce qu'il y a des joueurs qui
font toujours partie de l'effectif on
parlait de verratti il y a Marquinhos
même si Marquinho c'est un joueur
sérieux moi je pense qu'il faut repartir
sur un nouveau cycle les dirigeants
parisiens alors c'est Campo c'est le
directeur sportif qui est arrivé la
saison dernière à essayer de construire
un nouvel effectif en donnant un peu
plus de place à de jeunes français il a
aussi donné les clés à Christophe
Galtier il y a beaucoup de millions qui
ont été dépensés il y a un jour comme
vitilia aussi qui est très intéressant
qui est arrivé même si là je crois que
c'est 150 millions d'euros sur le
dernier mercato voilà justement ils ont
tellement investi sur ce mercato d'été
avec des profits alors qui ont pas tous
donné on va dire satisfaction entière
satisfaction mais que sur le mercato
d'hiver quand il a fallu ajuster un
petit peu et trouver de nouveaux profils
ben ils étaient à sec les Parisiens les
cadres et les et les stars ou les
joueurs comme tu dis que l'on dit qui
sont les meilleurs du monde ne montre
pas l'exemple donc du coup tu as beau
rajouter des pièces qui sont peut-être
moins moins fort ou petite peine de
talent mais ils ne sont eux non plus ne
sont pas à 100% et le problème c'est ça
c'est que ces joueurs ne sont pas à 100%
quand ils sont sur le terrain
quelles sont les solutions du coup
est-ce qu'il faut changer l'entraîneur
fini
tout à l'heure en haut et puis revoir
peut-être un retour
il parle de beaucoup de monde c'est
toujours pareil c'est je sais pas ce que
peut-être aussi le fantasme
toutes ces stars il y a quelques-uns et
puis tu te rends compte rien que le
salaire de de comment de Messi combien
de bons joueurs que tu peux prendre à la
place qui vont jouer collectif qui vont
pas jouer quand on regarde le match
contre le contre le Bayern le Bayern
Messi existe ils ont été inexistants
même si on comptait sur eux pour
débloquer c'est là qu'on doit les voir
pourquoi c'est aussi parce que il y a
pas la capacité parce que pour avoir des
ballons et pour dominer un match est-ce
qu'on disait quand le PSG match PSG l'OM
c'était deux matchs avec les mêmes
effectifs quasiment et deux états
d'esprit complètement différents et deux
résultats différents là si l'équipe
une alimentent pas devant bah tu tu ne
peux rien faire
juste pour rebondir par rapport à ça
mais aller du côté des supporters le
président des ultra là c'est beaufredo
qui s'appelle c'est la première fois
depuis ici qui s'exprime qui dit qu'il
est qu'il est dégoûté qu'il est qu'il
est complètement là je sais pas ce qui
va se passer contre Rennes dimanche mais
j'ai hâte de voir ce qui va se passer
j'y serai mais génial que par des
championnats mais bon euh voilà c'est
ils sont vraiment il est vraiment
dégoûté et c'est tous les supporters
juste c'est un exemple moi je regardais
le match et c'est un exemple de
comportement Mbappé on le sait c'est
celui qui tient le PSG à l'heure
actuelle c'était un excellent joueur
c'est OK plus honnête il a dit c'est on
a fait notre maximum c'est maximum sauf
que avoir fait son maximum alors moi je
suis pas un pro foot d'accord mais il a
avoir fait son maximum lorsque je vois
un Cristiano Ronaldo comme il se démène
sur un terrain de foot à courir partout
moi j'ai une image du Portugal quand ils
étaient menée là et où il courait
partout partout parce que ils étaient
menés et que ça allait pas et quand
j'ouvre quand je vois quand même le
comportement Mbappé qui est un super
joueur certes je reviens pas là-dessus
mais quand même il a quand même pas un
rendement des mecs qui veut se défoncer
pour l'équipe parce qu'il couvre pas et
normalement le terrain quand même certes
quand tu as le ballon il fait la
différence il a ses qualités mais dans
l'état non mais il va pas le chercher
non plus dans l'état d'esprit oui mais
c'est tout comme ça je pense que c'est
quand même l'esprit général du groupe
c'est que ben on se repose un peu sur
sur ma paye la même comportement et ça
m'a aidé juste avant que Grégory va dire
quelque chose
Mbappe a dit on a fait le maximum non et
il a dit Mbappé il a dit c'est le
maximum que l'on peut faire oui oui et
là il a dit au mois de septembre au mois
de septembre il avait déjà dit tu vois
et il l'a redit là tu vois juste voilà
pour moi le vrai problème c'est
l'institution PSG il y a de nombreuses
personnes qui l'ont dit ils sont même
pas passer par le PSG Ibrahimovic à
l'époque elle avait dit que il y avait
pas les structures d'un grand club en
tout cas qui se fixait ce genre
d'ambition car le ventre chez Loti aussi
s'en était allé et les accepter les les
la séduction du Real Madrid à l'époque
parce qu'il avait été assez agacé qu'on
le remet très vite en question il y a un
vrai problème d'institution le casser
Serge Aurier qui est assez aussi
problématique qui dit aussi combien bah
comment dire un entraîneur peut être
remise en question Serge janvier je
rappelle il avait insulté son entraîneur
Laurent Blanc à l'époque on l'avait mis
en dehors du groupe la décision avait
été vite prise à l'époque on l'a
réintégré assez rapidement alors qu'il
avait quand même été comment dire il a
été l'auteur du d'une erreur assez
manifeste une faute professionnelle
aurait j'aurais dû même carrément être
viré du PSG les nombreux débordements
etc
pour son match quand il était avec la
réserve donc c'était c'était la qualité
et après bah voilà sur l'effectif quand
on prend les entrées du Bayern face au
PSG il n'y a BRI il y a Leroy Sané les
joueurs comme jouer au camp de Hello qui
sont rentrés on est quand même sur un
effectif d'une autre envergure pour
lutter pour les premières personnes
également et moins cher également alors
le PSG quand même toujours en course
pour emporter un onzième titre de
champion de France on fera un nouveau
point d'ici à la fin de la saison et je
rappelle que le PSG va s'installer cet
été dans son nouveau centre
d'entraînement à Poissy peut-être qui
emporteront la Ligue des Champions quand
ils seront à Poissy on ne sait pas on
verra l'avenir alors on va maintenant
passer à notre troisième thématique elle
concerne la box dis-moi après sa défaite
contre Martin bas-collet livres
inoisonné Oka perdu contre son
compatriote Carlos takham ce samedi soir
au Zénith de Paris après 10 Rand intense
les arbitres ont décidé de donner la
victoire à son adversaire âgé de 42 ans
l'avenir du boxeur originaire de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes s'obscurcit Tony
Yoka a dit vouloir revenir plus fort
dans les prochains mois mais après deux
défaites consécutives il paraît
aujourd'hui peu probable de voir les
Viennois décrocher un type de champion
du monde dans le futur en tout cas dans
dans les prochaines années alors la
question sur cette thématique Tony Yoka
sera-t-il champion du monde
je donne pas de limite de temps champion
du monde non à tous les catégories
autour de cette table
Yann pourquoi on l'avait déjà dit avant
le avant le avant le combat c'était déjà
le combat de la dernière chance pour
pouvoir reprendre une place dans la dans
la hiérarchie mondiale voilà là il perd
contre
ta cam
vétéran maintenant de même si dans la
catégorie des des lourds à l'âge là je
n'ai pas n'est pas n'est pas trop
problématique d'ailleurs ta cam parle de
monter un combat contre contrebas collé
voilà
en plus ce sont deux collés ce sont deux
combattants d'origine africaine donc du
coup il y aurait un il y aura un truc un
petit peu un petit un truc un peu plus
sympa en plus dans l'histoire mais c'est
vrai que là bah ouais pour pour Tony
Yoka et les portes les portes se
referment quoi donc alors
ouais ce qui parce que là il avait quand
même ouais il a reste que c'était le
manque de compétition parce que c'est
vrai que dis-moi ça dis-moi sans combat
ça fait ça fait beaucoup
mais oui c'est c'est le temps de prépa
on est on est d'accord mais généralement
ils essaient de d'en faire tous les
trois quatre mois mais je suis je suis
je suis je suis assez d'accord sur sur
ce genre de combat dis-moi de
préparation ça me semble pas ça me
semble pas être anormal et donc bah
ouais là il va ça va être très très je
pense que ça va être compliqué de de
pouvoir avoir des clés tout simplement
genre vous qui le suivez Tony alors pour
moi
genre oui déçu parce que oui
pour moi
Tony Yoka
ne sera pas champion du monde parce que
Yann l'a dit les chaises là pour pouvoir
prétendre aller chercher un titre
champion du monde ça ça ça sent mauvais
de plus en plus mais outre outre ce
phénomène je pense que sur le combat par
lui-même
il a pas de punch quoi il a pas de punch
il a pas de punch on a un tacam à 42 ans
qui a mis des coups qui ont fait mal il
a une tête de plus il a une allonge il a
l'envergure beaucoup plus
impressionnante que lui il les coups
parce que techniquement il a passé une
boxe qui aurait pu être efficace sauf
que ces coups n'ont pas porté c'est cool
n'ont pas porté c'est cool on pas marqué
tu as quand même et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je me pose la véritable
question est-ce que Tony Yoka est
vraiment le champion le grand champion
que tout le monde veut bien qu'on se
dise quoi parce que finalement les deux
grands combats qu'il a eu dans sa
carrière parce qu'après on disait les
videurs de boîte et les bouchées du
Macumba mais là il a eu quand même
bacoller et ta cam qui sont les deux
références et il a perdu les deux
combats donc aujourd'hui est-ce que
vraiment est-ce que est-ce qu'on en a
pas fait un grand
rougeurs avant qu'il ait des résultats
c'est un petit peu là aussi le problème
français quoi on met on met les sportifs
au niveau avant qu'il le fasse
sportivement et je pense que dans ce
dans le cas de Tony Yoka c'était
malheureusement ça lui a desservi parce
que mais même si techniquement il a
progressé mais le résultat moi j'ai
trouvé qu'il a énormément manqué de
punch et de puissance dans ses coups
voilà Philippe il y a beaucoup de choses
on l'a vu dès qu'il est arrivé pour
combattre on lisait sa peur sur lui on
lisait sa peur sur lui on voyait qu'il
avait peur c'est incroyable je veux dire
un peu la pression
un gros contrat comme d'un million
d'euros pour comment pour 15 combats il
lui en reste deux il lui en reste dont
un le prochain le 24 juin on sait pas
encore contre qui enfin bref après il
sait pas ce que c'est en plus c'est
250000 euros par combat qui touche en
plus il faut regarder ça et là je me dis
c'est quand même je veux dire je pense
aussi tu as qu'à me l'a dit lui il a que
cinq personnes dans son entourage
comme Tony Yoka il en a 20
c'est quand même incroyable quand même 5
20 est-ce que c'est pas aussi un
problème d'entretenir quand tu vois
qu'il était comme beaucoup plus grand il
a il allonge et beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus il y a 10 ans
je dis c'est que c'est quand même je
veux dire mais il a dit tu as qu'à l'as
dit après il en a encore reparler
aujourd'hui il en a encore au parler je
veux dire voilà il y a est-ce que c'est
son entourage pas lui pas il a des
capacités si tu veux mais la pluie va
aller plus il va être il va il va avoir
des capacités mondiales
donc en parler tout le monde dit qu'il a
une vraie box il a une il a c'est un
très bon boxeur techniquement maintenant
entre la box amateur et la box
professionnel on peut briller
effectivement avoir des médailles
olympiques mais derrière quand on passe
sur le niveau professionnel c'est c'est
autre chose moi aussi je suis je suis de
la vie des camarades je pense que il
sera pas champion du monde en tout cas
ça va être très compliqué pour deux
raisons on sait que la box professionnel
il y a aussi très peu d'occasions qui se
présentent dans la carrière d'un boxeur
pro alors il a que deux défaites il en
faudrait pas une de plus parce que là je
pense que ça ni le rêve vraiment
totalement ses chances mais ça reste
compliqué il a eu ces deux opportunités
avec des profils plus ou moins
similaires ta cam certes un peu plus
petit que Yuka mais qu'on l'a vu arriver
sur sur le ring ouais moi j'avais peur
pour eux qu'il y a enfin j'ai vu Takam
arrivé sur le ring très sûr de lui 42
ans bon sa carrière l'essentiel de sa
carrière c'est un 40 victoires cette
défaite est un nul il a fait des gros
match contre Joe Joyce Anthony Joshua
donc c'était pas
un tocard comme on dit dans le jardin
alors lui il a peut-être pris aussi un
peu comme un jubilé quoi que il veut
encore combattre derrière donc il
arrivait sur le ring sans pression au
contraire de Yuka moi je suis d'accord
avec Philippe moi je l'ai senti tendu
avant le match il est apparu sur le ring
30 minutes peut-être avant le combat et
on sentait il avait ses petits écouteurs
on sentait qu'il était
dans sa bulle mais dans une bulle pas
forcément très saine j'ai l'impression
il a il était pas totalement concentré
sur ce combat et je me questionne moi
sur son niveau réel alors peut-être
qu'il a effectivement une très bonne
technique mais là dans ce combat il a
été plutôt sur la défensive il a été
dans la stratégie de plutôt accepter
accepter les coûts de ta cam mais il a
il l'a mal fait il a il a très peu tenté
dans ce combat et donc moi je me pose
aussi la question du niveau réel du
boxeur et je rejoins Jean sur est-ce
qu'on l'a pas mis trop trop vite avec ce
gros contrat juteux avec Canal+ de le
suivre dans sa conquête alors que on
sait que bah voilà un titre mondial ça
se construit sur plusieurs années ce qui
n'a pas voulu aller trop vite aller trop
tôt sur sur ce titre mondial et
peut-être plutôt que de le construire
sur la durée moi c'est la question que
je me pose aujourd'hui après tu as qu'à
m'a félicité quand même il faut
reconnaître
donc
fair-play comment yokai il a presque
combat
11 victoires et du coup de défaite pas
mal de 31 ans il va avoir 30 ans dans
les dans les prochains
c'est clair que c'est largement jouable
mais
là dedans et ce qui va avoir des
adversaires vont accepter de combattre
contre lui pour pour des titres mondiaux
ça reste bien sûr genre techniquement
moi ce qui me fait peur et ce qui m'a
vraiment
interpellé sur ce combat c'est que il
avait quand même une allonge beaucoup
plus supérieure à son adversaire et que
c'est lui qui aurait dû mener le combat
en le tenant à distance avec une allonge
puissante avec une allonge pour le tenir
à distance les choses qui n'a pas fait
parce que il plaçait il plaçait ses
directs du gauche il plaçait ses
allonges mais mais c'était des touches
c'était pas c'était pas c'était pas pour
le repousser c'était plus des touches
pour le maintenir mais mais tu as quand
même rentrer quand même et c'est lui qui
portait les coups les plus
coaching ou je sais la faute de yoga
précis sur la boxe moi je c'est mon
ressenti sur la à la vue du combat
est-ce que c'est un manque de
préparation il y a certainement mais
l'opération physiquement il y a une
photo tout à l'heure on a vu une petite
folie une photo de combattants quand on
voit la musculature de ta cam et qu'on
voit la musculature de yoga et sur le
combat
personnellement je me suis fait la
remarque j'ai dit mais il a maigri il a
fondu et sur le combat il a pris 4 kg et
il est plus il a jamais été aussi j'ai
atténué les commentaires les
commentaires et ils ont dit qu'ils
avaient il avait pris 4 kg alors oui il
a pris 4 kg mais quand on voit les bras
de ta cam sur le combat et les bras du
yoga on se dit que mais la puissance on
sait où elle était et le résultat il est
là aussi il est arrivé sur scène avec
son peignoir ouvert là on voyait ses
muscles sérieux moi j'ai ouais
fait pas mal donc du coup il a pas peur
d'approcher et de et d'aller mettre et
d'aller mettre sa puissance à lui parce
que en effet ta cam il a la puissance
donc bah oui en effet pour l'instant
Tommy yokai lui manque il est à la
capacité de placer ses coups mais il a
pas il a pas la puissance pour fermer il
n'a pas l'efficacité d'aller là il place
il fait pas mal à ses adversaires bon en
tout cas on va continuer à suivre Tony
OK et il y aura prochainement d'autres
combats sûrement des plus petits combats
à l'avenir pour Tony Yoka qui va essayer
de remonter petit à petit au classement
de la box pour viser peut-être dans les
prochaines années un titre de champion
du monde on passe à notre page débat
[Musique]
alors on va maintenant parler de
cyclisme ce dimanche 5 mars le
Paris-Nice c'est parti pour la 14e année
consécutive depuis les Yvelines à La
Verrière c'était une grande première
pour la commune de 6000 habitants qui a
travaillé pendant plusieurs mois pour
préparer cette journée placée sous le
signe du cyclisme on l'écoute très très
grande fierté pour la verrière de
d'accueillir une compétition hors norme
avec des milliers de de spectateurs qui
sont attendus avec beaucoup de
téléspectateurs du monde entier qui
auront les yeux rivés sur la verrière et
le Mesnil-Saint-Denis donc c'est une
fierté on a aussi un très beau village
d'animation et j'ai pu voir beaucoup de
joie beaucoup de sourires pour tous les
âges avec notamment de nombreux enfants
sur une thématique très populaire le
vélo qui parle à tout le monde qui
rassemble et donc c'est un un moment
unique pour la verrière pour l'histoire
vous avez suivi un petit peu cette
première étape à La Verrière vous allez
trouver ça comment toute la comment
à part une qui a été annulée pour cause
de vent vers Nice mais ouais je pense
que moi je me dis que même si c'était
des étapes qu'on disait roulantes si tu
veux il y a eu il y a eu quelque chose
il y a eu une attaque de poggatchard
dans Comment dans une dans la voilà et
je trouve que ça a joué parce qu'il a
pris 6 secondes et ça l'a vu a permis
d'être devant après et tout il y a eu
des c'est vrai certes deux arrivées au
sprint mais je pense que ils ont été
beaucoup dans le au départ sur le dans
le 78 et je trouve que c'est moi j'ai
trouvé bon bien sûr on parle de
des Yvelines mais je trouve que c'était
une belle une belle course en plus une
bagarre à trois presque à deux je dirais
parce que en plus un Français deuxième
ça fait depuis je crois Arthur vichaud
je crois depuis 2014 je crois que quand
il avait pas été qui avait fini 3e je
crois ou 2004 ou 2014 ouais c'est ça et
Gaudu comment je veux dire à prix de la
à montrer de la résistance à Shark était
au dessus largement dès le premier étape
où il a la jeté les prémisses de son
succès
pogatchard bon comme d'habitude on est
content on voit les beaux plans aériens
des Yvelines les passages les passages
classiques les passages connus cette
côte des 17 tournants notamment et voilà
pour la ville de La Verrière ça permet
d'avoir
ce type d'événement pour une ville on
sait qu'il y a en mutation qui essaye de
changer aussi son image au quotidien
donc c'est une belle chose pour les
habitants que d'avoir ce bel événement
et avec en plus des cyclistes de renom
on parlait voilà de ce duel cette saison
qui se lance avec ce duel pogacchard
bingo Gordes on a eu on a eu les
prémices de ce duel qui va qui va se
lancer sur cette saison la verrière
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé vous euh
en fait avec un tout petit peu de recul
quand vous entendez en fait ça m'énerve
parce que comme vous les voyez monter
justement les 17 tournants vous quand
vous y êtes tous les dimanches ou
régulièrement le dimanche bah vous en
avez et que là ils vont passer
voilà et je me souviens d'ailleurs une
des premières images que j'ai d'un coton
de d'un peloton et professionnel monté
monter les étais tournant il y avait
ravitaillement juste en bas et Gilbert
Duclos la salle prend une musette et
monte tous les 17 tournants en piochant
dans la musette et cetera les mains sans
les mains et vous comme vous êtes dans
les étonnants vous en bavez la
différence entre toi et un sportif de
Lyon
mais c'est un esprit de courge je pense
que si on l'a passé en course ça ce
serait différent quand on est à
l'entraînement on n'a pas les mêmes les
mêmes envies alors le lendemain mais par
contre c'est vrai que même mis au
million la chapelle etc et on a vu pour
moi un des plus beaux Parisis depuis
très très longtemps alors attendez nous
vous avancez pas sur sur la question
alors le lendemain si le 6 mars la
petite commune de Bazainville a
accueilli l'épreuve pour la première
fois le maire de Balzac il avait encore
du mal à réaliser on l'écoute
aujourd'hui ce qui me plaît le plus
c'est de voir beaucoup de gens venir et
j'espère que notre village leur plaira
de voir les élèves de l'école heureux
comme tout
en voyant les cyclistes les motards et
toute l'organisation je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse nous le reposer et donc ça
sera une fois mais je vous dis quand ça
sera fini je pense que je pourrais
savoir
alors ce départ depuis Bazainville on
voit un maire heureux c'est un petit peu
ça aussi l'esprit du Parisis Grégory bah
oui c'est ça c'est lui donner
l'opportunité assez petite ville d'avoir
des événements de cet ampleur c'est pas
tous les jours qu'on a une course
cycliste de de cette ampleur voilà même
si c'est que le Parisi ça reste quand
même une compétition connue c'est la
Course au Soleil voilà elle a ça reste
quand même une belle compétition oui il
a dit que c'était une fois dans une vie
hein peut-être le Paris ça à Bazainville
le départ
de Paris Nice que c'est vrai la preuve
je veux dire donc non je pense que
c'est des très des souvenirs parce que
il y avait une course qui s'appelait
Bois d'Arcy Bazainville niveau régional
et avec une arrivée dans une dans une
dans une bonne côte avec un circuit et
c'est vrai que Ben malheureusement
ces cours amateurs elles disparaissent
aussi parce que bah le cycliste a un peu
mauvaise image mauvaise c'est embêtant
de bloquer la circulation pour pour des
cyclistes amateurs alors on arrive
toujours à le faire pour pour des
grandes épreuves tout World Tour mais
c'est vrai que le cycliste amateur se
retrouve quand même lui dans des zones
industrielles pour pouvoir faire ses
compétitions et c'est un peu un peu
dommage
alors les spectateurs ont pu voir les
deux cyclistes les plus en vue du moment
le slovençage poggatchard et le Danois
garde les deux quoi emporter les trois
derniers tours de France Paris c'était
un peu une avant première avant que les
deux hommes s'affrontent de nouveau sur
la Grande Boucle cet été on écoute le
directeur d'ASO c'est un plateau
absolument phénoménal oui il a la
revanche du dernier Tour de France qui a
enthousiasmé tout le monde
c'est formidable de l'avoir dès le mois
de mars ça va être un combat des chefs
ils ont montré dans les premières
courses de l'année en Espagne chacun de
leur côté qu'ils étaient très très forts
qu'ils ont gagné quasiment tout toutes
les courses dans laquelle ils étaient
inscrits et là c'est vraiment le combat
des chefs qui nous attend avec d'autres
coureurs de talents
c'était le premier jour à La Verrière
depuis pogacia à emporté ce Paris-Nice
la question sur cette thématique est-ce
que c'était le plus beau Paris-Nice du
21e siècle qu'on a pu voir dans les
Yvelines
quand on voit ce plateau oui
du 21e siècle alors oui pour vous bon
vous êtes tous d'accord après il y a une
alors il y a du
jarriere
d'un beau Paris-Nice
ou à la Philippe avait porté le maillot
et avait peut-être gagné un contre la
montre et donc
voilà l'attrait des Français avait été
et donc je me souviens il doit perdre
sur la dernière étape pour une fin ouais
pas grand chose donc il avait une
défaillance en dernier dans les deux
dernières étapes Christian Prudhomme
parle de scénario la Hitchcock sur le
Paris-Nice
en effet en effet c'est clair que c'est
une galère c'est une course qui est
généralement se joue à très peu de temps
cette année ça n'a pas été le cas parce
que pocketchar a été vraiment dominateur
et même je trouve que ce garçon est même
intelligent dans sa construction de
course parce que il savait qu'il y avait
une étape qui jouerait en sa défaveur le
contre le monde par équipe ou en effet
il perd une quarantaine de secondes sur
le contrat de par équipe mais comme il
avait été marqué des points des des
secondes sur les sprints bonification
sur les étapes précédentes mais
finalement à la sortie de ce de ce
contrat de par équipe il était à une
vingtaine de secondes seulement du
leader de la course qui n'était même pas
Jonas à ce moment-là donc du coup bah il
reste dans le match et c'est vrai que je
trouve que dans l'intelligence de pour
ne pas ce que c'est vrai que se
retrouver à 40 secondes mais c'est plus
c'est plus la même chose ben là non
j'avais été il avait été marqué des des
secondes de bonifications au préalable
et ça lui a permis de rester dans le
match et de pouvoir asseoir sa victoire
sur les deux étapes qui qui qui
ont su après ouais il gagne trois étapes
sur Paris - Nice aujourd'hui pour moi le
seul regret c'est il manque une victoire
française sur une étape et là ça aurait
été top piscine genre qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez de ce pari quand on voit le
plateau surtout quand on voit alors le
plateau Paris
c'était était fabuleux cette année
personnellement je préfère le praliner
et je préfère le Paris-Brest mais c'est
c'est personnel j'ai un avis personnel
mais sinon Paris-Nice pourquoi pas j'en
ai jamais goûté mais
peut-être que ça vient donc tout a été
dit tout a été dit et c'est vrai que une
course prestigieuse comme le paradis
elle est prestigieuse par rapport au
plateau des sportifs qui qui viennent et
qui viennent la courir la petite cerise
il manquait juste un gun je pense qu'il
y avait dû quasi
je suis pas sûr que l'évolution
qui partira des Yvelines aussi je le
rappelle cet été depuis le vélodrome de
la semaine de 50 ans en Yvelines terre
de cyclisme
il dit la revanche du Tour de France
pour moi c'est pas la revanche du Tour
de France c'est juste le roone 1 de la
saison 2023 la revanche du Tour de
France ce sera sur le Tour de France au
mois de juillet voilà la seule chose que
je le dis déjà la dernière fois dommage
qui est pas un deuxième round avant le
Tour de France entre les deux sur sur
une épreuve comme le comme le Dauphiné
libéré par exemple mais mais voilà c'est
juste le roman entre les deux entre
Paris
ils ont pas la possibilité de de se
retrouver de se
retrouverie en tout cas les cyclistes se
sloven sur ce début de saison sont en
forme il y a eu pogacia sur le Paris
Nice et primo sur le tirage très
rapidement qui sera le vainqueur du Tour
de France un petit pronostic très
rapidement un nom
c'est beaucoup trop tôt
je ne donne rien parce que c'est trop
comme la saison et la vérité du mois de
mars ne sera pas la même au mois de
juillet
moi je suis très mauvais en pronostic
mais justement les pocketcharpe
donc un français va gagner cette année
le Tour de France je vous l'annonce
alors on va maintenant parler football
avec un très bon début de saison et
notamment un bon début de saison d'année
début d'année 2003 pour Versailles mais
Versailles patine un peu ces derniers
temps les versets se sont inclinés
contre Concarneau à domicile un
concurrent direct pour la montée ce sont
inclinés juste après face à Nancy à
l'extérieur de 1 ils se sont reprises ce
lundi en battant à domicile à Bastille à
Borgo 1-0 les derniers du classement
avec ses résultats ils ont ils sont pour
l'instant à la première place du
classement avec un point d'avance sur
Martigues au-delà du terrain il y a des
problèmes en coulisse Michael miché en
charge de recrutement d'y vouloir partir
en fin de saison pour un climat plus
sain il y a eu un changement
d'entraîneur avec l'arrivée de Chris ça
bouge beaucoup en interne on n'arrive
même plus à suivre à nous ici à ATV 78
alors la question sur cette thématique
le FC Versailles est-il en crise oui ou
non
la question est un peu provocatrice
[Musique]
alors pourquoi Philippe
sur le résultat sportif non parce qu'ils
sont premiers c'est quand même pas mal
quand même déjà d'être pris même s'ils
sont quatre ou cinq équipes à être c'est
serré mais en crise oui en crise au
niveau extraordif changement
d'entraîneur changement directeur
sportif
des soucis dans l'effectif des soucis au
niveau des partenaires c'est ça aussi
des soucis que ils pensent que Simon ils
vont pas pouvoir rester déjà à bon
Versailles c'est pas possible pas
pouvoir rester à Jean-Bouin à jamboins
déjà ils ont qu'une tribune parce que ça
suffit mille spectateurs c'est le
maximum allez à Lille ou aller au Mans
comme il le disent c'est c'est
pratiquement impossible en plus Simon
dans Ligue 2 ce qu'on a vu sur les
dernières années il y a eu le resta il y
a eu en parlant de l'Oise Chambly et il
y a eu d'autres qui se sont expatriés
tous les trois tous les deux équipes là
ils sont descendus en s'expatrillant ils
sont descendus ils sont descendus tout
de suite et puis c'est je sais pas non
c'est Versailles c'est faut qu'il joue à
Versailles malheureusement bon à cause
de commande des commandes du château de
Versailles est-ce qu'il y a bon c'est
pas possible mais bon voilà donc mais
rien n'est fait ils sont quatre voilà on
peut pas voilà genre pour vous pas de
crise
il faut quand même se souvenir quand
même que Versailles monte et que quand
même il joue ils sont premiers quoi ils
sont premiers de poules alors certes ils
sont ils se passent en premier mais ils
sont premiers ils montent quand même de
division inférieure avec certes de
l'ambition objectivement monter en Ligue
2 mais ils sont sûrement le plus gros
budget du championnat on est d'accord
donc parler de crise d'un club qui monte
alors que tous les clubs qui montent
dans n'importe quel sport collectif on
parle toujours déjà de maintien la
première année pour voir un petit peu
prendre la température du niveau au
dessus là on a une équipe qui monte qui
est première à deux poules et on veut
parler de crise
au vu des résultats je pense pas qu'il y
a une crise après effectivement en
interne il y a vraiment des gros
problèmes mais qu'on ne le sait pas mais
sportivement pour l'instant ça se ça se
reflète pas et une équipe qui provient
on peut pas dire qu'elle soit en crise
d'accord mais pas de crise sur les
résultats purement sportifs on peut être
peut-être un peu déçu parce que dans le
championnat national qui est très serré
on a vu Versailles perte deux fois
gagner reprendre la tête du championnat
avec toujours Concarneau qui peut
revenir à hauteur parce qu'ils ont un
match en retard et joueurs de concours
ça va très vite dans le championnat
national et on peut être déçu
effectivement qu'avec bah c'est deux
contre performances c'est deux défaites
d'affilée bah Versailles aurait
peut-être pu même creuser l'écart d'ores
et déjà dans le championnat de National
parce que ça va très vite et ils
auraient pu peut-être aller faire un
coup à ce moment-là de la saison
maintenant est-ce que ils ont un bon
rythme de champion ça j'en doute parce
que quand même ils sont ils ont ils ont
si défaites cette saison 12 victoires
sinue si défaites si des fêtes c'est
peut-être un peu beaucoup enfin
heureusement Marty je crois très peu de
défaites mais beaucoup plus de matchs
dans dans championnat de National donc
moi je suis un petit peu déçu voilà ces
deux défaites d'affilée aurait pu
permettre de de prendre un petit peu
d'avance maintenant voilà ils avancent
effectivement entre guillemets à vue
cette saison avec tous les problèmes
extra sportifs tous toutes les tensions
en interne pour le moment ça a l'air
plutôt de marcher sur sur le terrain
mais moi j'attends de voir la suite avec
impatience voir si justement bah tout
toutes ces coulisses vont pas à un
moment jouer aussi dans la tête des
joueurs Thibault Jacques on a reçu
récemment qui nous disait voilà qui
affirmait qui affirmé que le l'objectif
maintenant c'était la Ligue 2 à ce stade
de la saison a dit que bah voilà ils
essayaient quand même de faire fille et
essayer de faire abstraction de tous ces
coulisses mais il a paniqué qu'il y
avait des problèmes en coulisses on fera
le bilan à la fin de la saison pour le
moment ça a l'air plutôt bien ce se
dérouler et en plus j'en le disais très
bien pour un premier on parle quand même
d'un premier qui a certes des ambitions
mais c'est tout de même un premier
on a connaissance de problèmes en
coulisse maintenant
le FC Versailles aime la difficulté tout
simplement voilà c'est ce que on
pourrait dire souvenez-vous la dernière
de pas mal hein finalement dans ce son
dans les sports on a on a le PSG mais
aussi
souvenez-vous de l'année dernière de du
parcours en Coupe de France qui a été un
parcours très très difficile du fait de
pas pouvoir jouer à domicile même si et
voilà donc de voir s'expétrier
s'expatrier à chaque fois et ben moi je
pense que oui en effet le FC Versailles
m aime la difficulté donc quand tout va
bien bah ils sont pas contents donc
comme ça va bien sportivement bah il
faut trouver des trucs pour aller de
comme dans un couple dans un couple ben
voilà il y a des couples qui aiment bien
chicaner pour pour faire pour pour faire
vivre ben voilà là c'est pareil c'est
Versailles
Philippe c'est un vrai c'est un vrai
problème à éluciner d'ici la fin de la
saison ça c'est par contre en effet il
ne faut pas passer
après c'est pareil si le PSG se
délocalise au Stade de France du coup
Versailles pour être aller au Parc des
Princes parce que le Parc des Princes il
va être fait donc voilà ils ont même
parlé avec crédit des discussions avec
beaucoup
ils ont pu jouer à Duvauchelle à Créteil
aussi ça a rien donné mais c'est pas
pour moi c'est pas
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible déjà là c'est pas
possible à jamboing on en parlera la
prochaine fois parce que c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission on va terminer
comme d'habitude par une citation
aujourd'hui je vous propose une citation
de Dick fossbury l'athlète américain qui
a créé le saut en hauteur sur le dos
décédé récemment toute cette histoire
n'est qu'un accident j'ai mais sauté
mais je ne parvenais pas à franchir des
bars élevées autrement que sur le dos
c'est donc un incroyable
malentendu je vous laisse méditer sur
cette phrase à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]